there's a great story i just saw on cbs
evening news
i don't remember the last time i uttered
that sentence but there was a really
great story on cbs evening news about
some dads in louisiana there was a
school in louisiana where 23 students
had been arrested for fighting over the
course of three days and the schools
were useless and the politicians were
useless and the administrators were
useless at stopping this and so what
happened
a bunch of dads stepped in and started
keeping the peace in the school and what
do you know everything got better
nobody here has a degree in school
counseling
no majors in criminal justice no no your
qualifications are dancing
we decided the best people who can take
care of our kids or who for us i
immediately felt a form of safety we
stopped fighting people started going to
class how could that be
you ever heard of a look
a look dads have the power to do that
yes
not many people know it but yes
they just make funny jokes like oh hey
your student's untied but it's really
not untied
they hate it they're so embarrassed by
it
and it's that perfect mix of tough love
and gentle ribbing that dads do so well
that has helped transform this school
the school has really just been like
happy and you can feel it because not
everybody has a father a father figure
at home or a male period in their life
so just to be here
makes a big difference
so there is so much wisdom in this
segment and there's so much wisdom in
what these dads are
doing i think there are two levels here
there's the first level which i think we
all know which is that fatherlessness
causes the decay of society you've
noticed this especially in the black
community because
rates of out of wedlock birth or some
something over 70 percent now
and
and fatherlessness has been blamed for a
lot of the sort of social pathologies
specifically among black americans and
it's true wherever it rears its ugly
head this problem of fatherlessness so
we all know yeah you got to protect the
family you start with good families you
keep the father at home you're going to
have a much better society but there's
there's a deeper level of wisdom even
here too
what are the fathers doing
the fathers are
showing and in the home and at the
schools they're showing up
and providing leadership
and a good example
and some levity you know some some of
these little jokes the dad jokes that
everyone
talks about end restraint
and authority
and limits
and the look what did that girl say she
said he said how do these dads do it
it's not like they have any degrees it's
not like they've got any particular
governmental authority she goes you ever
hear of a look
yeah you ever you know and dad gives you
what is that look that look is
a warning
that look is a threat
but that that warning and that threat is
coming from someone who does love you
and who does want what's best for you
and who is entrusted with your care so
he doesn't want to go kill you he
doesn't want to destroy your life but he
wants to
exercise his authority
and to constrain your desires and basis
appetites to make sure that you flourish
this is what politics does you know that
i go on the road a fair bit and
sometimes when i go on the road i go
solo and i'd like to know that my wife
and sweet little baby can know who is
outside the door before they open that
door and sometimes i take the family
with me and then i still get incredible
peace of mind from ring
with ring you can keep an eye on your
home not just that you all know about
the video doorbell where you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door
wherever you are whether you're in the
home at the office on the beach on the
other side of the world
but you can keep an eye on every inch of
your home inside and out you control it
all from the very simple app
it's extraordinarily easy to install
even i can do it
and with the full ring alarm system you
can subscribe get even even more
features and it's extremely inexpensive
it's just a terrific product all the way
around protect your home anytime from
anywhere with ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles canon wles for a special offer
on a ring alarm security kit today build
a system that is right for your home
have it up and running in minutes that
is ring dot com slash knowles can aw les
ring.com slash knowles the family is the
fundamental building block of society
it's the smallest political unit then
you have the local community then you
have the state then you have the
national government but the principles
apply the whole time
and a good political community is not
libertine and licentious and doesn't say
just do whatever you want a good dad
doesn't say go do whatever you want oh
yeah go do a bunch of drugs stay out all
night drinking teenager yeah go sleep
with whoever you want yeah don't do your
homework if you don't want to do it i'm
a good dad because i'm respecting your
freedom no that's not freedom that's
going to destroy somebody
it doesn't work at the family level
doesn't work at
the local or the state or the national
level either
you need
wise leadership judgment prudence
restraint
the left
doesn't like that
the left blew out all of the restraints
and now they're reimposing them along
their own lines and the conservatives
are so stuck in a bunch of libertarian
claptrap that they won't do it either
when the left says let's legalize all
the drugs what does the right say okay
well actually i read some stupid
libertarian essay a few years ago so
yeah let's legalize all the drugs the
left says let's get rid of all sexual
moraes the right says well you know i'm
my i love liberty and so if liberty
means letting anyone sleep with whoever
they want however often they want
wherever with as many people that's
totally that's cool whatever let's do
that liberty no guys
take a lesson from those dads those dads
get it listen to those kids those kids
get it and look at the difference in
what's going on in those schools hey you
thanks for watching that clip i'm glad
you liked it i enjoyed producing that
clip for you sometimes people are not
told when i i put clips out there i
don't know maybe
our friends here at youtube maybe they
don't always want to tell people one way
you can ensure that that you will get
notifications ring that bell subscribe
the best way to ensure you get
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you